ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING THIS HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. I ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE ROOM
THE PANELISTS LISTED ON THE
AGENDA ARE APPEARING VIRTUALLY
USING ONLINE REMOTE
PARTICIPATION TECHNOLOGY. WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS HEARING ONLINE. THE PHONE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB FOR AT
ASM DOT CA. DOT G. O. V. SINCE
THE FROM CURRENTLY THE ONLY ONE
HERE WE WILL PASS FOR WILL CALL.
IN A MINUTE WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ISSUE ONE. DIVESTMENT FROM
RUSSIAN HOLDING STATE RETIREMENT
LIABILITIES AND OTHER PROPOSALS
FOR OUR FIRST ISSUE WE WILL HEAR
FROM OUR TO PENSION FUND SYSTEMS
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS AS PART OF
THIS PRESENTATION THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL HEAR AN UPDATE
ON THE STATE'S REQUIRE
CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER PROPOSITION
TWO AND THE COSTS ARE SPENDING
PLANS. AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO FURTHER REDUCE THE
STATE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE START THIS
HEARING WITH THE TRAGIC
SITUATION IN UKRAINE THAT
RESULTED FROM RUSSIA'S MILITARY
ASSAULT. AND THAT IS CURRENTLY
ONGOING AS WE SPEAK. AS WE ENTER
THE NINETEEN THE NINETEENTH THAT
A DAY OF THIS VIOLENT CONFLICT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM REQUESTED ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND. THAT THE
SYSTEM'S RESTRICT. RIGHT ACCESS
TO CALIFORNIA'S CAPITAL AND
INVESTMENTS TO SEIZE THE
PURCHASE OF ANY RUSSIAN DEBT.
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO
CONSIDERING LEGISLATION TO
DIVEST STATE PUBLIC FUNDS FROM
RUSSIA AND RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES A BI PARTISAN EFFORT.
WHICH I HAVE JOINED AS A CO
AUTHOR TODAY WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE LEADERSHIP TEAM AT CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS WHO WILL PROVIDE
THE SUB COMMITTEE WITH AN UPDATE
ON THE SYSTEM'S RESPONSES TO THE
TO THE VARIOUS CALLS FOR.
DIVESTMENT AS PART OF THE- THEIR
PRESENTATION WE WILL REQUEST
THAT THE SYSTEMS PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THEIR CURRENT
INVESTMENT IN RUSSIA OR RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AFFILIATED ENTITIES
AN UPDATE ON RECENT ACTIONS THE
SYSTEMS HAVE TAKEN AND AN UPDATE
ON. FUTURE OR PENDING ACTIONS
INCLUDING THE PAST TO LIQUIDATE
CURRENT RUSSIAN HOLDINGS LET'S
START WITH CALPERS FOR THIS
UPDATES WEEK FOR THIS UPDATE WE
ARE JOINED BY. MICHAEL COHEN
CHIEF FINANCIAL CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER AT CALPERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT'S A PLEASURE
TO- TO JOIN YOU- AT YOUR BUDGET
I HEARING I DID JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE A- QUICK UPDATE TO THE
RUSSIA ISSUE MY COMMENTS WELL-
ECHO OR CEO MARK THE PROCESS
COMMENT. AT JOINT HEARING THAT
TOOK PLACE LAST WEEK- WE DO
VIEW- THE RUSSIAN ISSUE AS-
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT THAN
SOME OF THE OTHER DIVESTMENT
BILLS THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT YOU'LL SEE US
OPPOSING. I IN THIS CASE-
REGARDING RUSSIA- CALPERS NEVER
OWNED ANY RUSSIAN DEBT- HOWEVER
AS OF MARCH SECOND WE DID. OKAY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF RUSSIAN AFFILIATED-
INVESTMENTS THAT THOSE TOTALS.
ROUGHLY SIXTY SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ARE
LAID OUT IN YOUR GENDER
MATERIALS. AND BUT WE HAVE
SEIZED ALL- ALL COMMITMENTS ARE
REGARDING CAPITAL FLOWING INTO
RUSSIA SINCE THAT THE INVASION
BEGAN- THE TWO COMPONENTS OF OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE ONE- PASSIVE-
SORT OF INDEX ORIENTED- THE
STOCK MARKET- FUNDS WHICH
TOTALED FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AS OF MARCH
SECOND AND THEN THE OTHER MAJOR-
INVESTMENT WE HAVE IS A MALL. UP
IN IN MOSCOW THAT WAS ABOUT A
THREE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALL OF THOSE VALUES- ARE
OBVIOUSLY DECLINING AS THE
INVASION CONTINUES IN UKRAINE
AND- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
REALLY- IMPOSED SANCTIONS- THAT
ARE- DEVALUING- RUSSIAN CURRENCY
AND CLOSING OFF- AT THE RUSSIAN
MARKETS TO- THE WESTERN WORLD'S-
SO WITH THAT. I'M HAPPY TO OUT
PASS IT ON TO OUR- MISTER AGENCY
CHARACTERS- FOR SIMILAR UPDATER
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
LET SAYS THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION WE'RE GONNA BE
JOINED BY CHRISTOPHER AILMAN THE
CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER AND
JULIE UNDERWOOD CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER CAL STIRS YOU MAY BEGIN
. VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. I CALIFORNIA TEACHERS- WE
HAD INVESTMENTS IN RUSSIA AS
PART OF THE EMERGING MARKETS IN
OUR EQUITY IN OUR FIXED INOME
PORTFOLIO- BACK IN MID FEBRUARY
THOSE ARE VALUED AT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS- OUR MANAGERS AND WE
INTERNALLY TOOK ACTIONS TO SELL
THAT DOWN. WE EVALUATE ALL OF
OUR PORTFOLIO AGAINST
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
GOVERNANCE RISK AS WELL AS
GEOPOLITICAL RISK. AND SO WE
SOLD THOSE INVESTMENTS DOWN- TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH. THE MARKET HASN'T
OPENED IN RUSSIA I ESTIMATE NOW
DUE TO THE DECLINE IN VALUES
THOSE ARE PROBABLY WORTH LESS
THAN A HUNDRED MILLION- WE
FROZEN- THAT PORTFOLIO- WE'VE
RESTRICTED RUSSIA AS AN
INVESTMENT. IN IN THE FUTURE-
MOVEMENT IN OUR PORTFOLIO- AND
THE INDEX PROVIDERS THAT WE WORK
WITH HAVE TAKEN RUSSIA OUT OF
THAT INDEX- OF STOCKS LONGER
CONSIDERED AN INVESTABLE MARKET.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
SITUATION- AND- EXTRACT OUR
CAPITAL AS WE CAN BUT RIGHT NOW
WITH THE CAPITAL CONTROLS IN
PLACE. IT'S GONNA BE A LONG TIME
IS VERY LIMITED TO GET THE REST
OF THAT MONEY OUT BUT IT IS NOT
LIQUID HOLDINGS- IN STOCKS IN
COMPANIES IN RUSSIA. AND ONE
FIXED INCOME- BOND HOLDINGS IN
RUSSIA. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
JUST A QUESTION IF I HEARD
CORRECTLY SO IT'S ONLY CAL STIRS
THAT HAS INVESTMENTS IN RUSSIA
RUSSIAN HOLDINGS. SAID ACCURATE. NO CALPERS DOES THIS WELL
SORRY MICHAEL DO YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION SURE I
THINK- THE DISTINGUISHING
CHARACTERISTIC BETWEEN OUR TWO
PORTFOLIOS IS REALLY ON THE
RUSSIAN DEBT- WHICH CALPERS
NEVER OWN- CAL STIRS AS YOU JUST
HEARD I HAS BEEN SELLING THAT
OFF- BUT WE DO HAVE- THROUGH THE
INDEX FUNDS AND THE MALL I
MENTIONED- WE DO HAVE RUSSIAN
HOLDINGS I CALPERS. AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND DID I HEAR
CORRECTLY THAT YOU ARE MOVING TO
A DIVERSE FROM THOSE HOLDINGS.
WELL AT THIS POINT- DIVESTMENT
REALLY IT'S IMPRACTICAL GIVEN-
THE CLOSING OF THE RUSSIAN STOCK
EXCHANGE AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
SANCTIONS SO OTHER THAN- THE
INDEX FUNDS- THAT CHRIS
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW WORD AND
SIMILAR ONES THAT ARE AT CLOSING
OFF- RUSSIAN. INVESTMENT GOING
FORWARD- AT THIS POINT- WE'RE
WATCHING- AND MONITORING BUT
THERE'S NOT- IN THE MARKET TO
BUY TO MAKE SUCH THAT. OKAY SO I
GUESS THAT SORT OF ADDRESSES THE
QUESTION THAT I HAD THE SYSTEMS
HAVE NOTED SOME POTENTIAL
CONSTRAINTS AND LIQUIDATING
CURRENT RUSSIAN HOLDINGS. CITING
SANCTIONS AND MARKET
RESTRICTIONS. THAT IS A COULD
YOU ELABORATE JUST A BIT ON THAT
PLEASE BOTH THE BOTH OF THE-
BOTH CALPERS AND CAL STIRS.
MICHAEL YOU WANT TO JUMP IN YEAH
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. SO AT THIS
POINT I'M CHRIS HILLMAN
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AT THIS
POINT THE RUSSIAN STOCK MARKET
HAS NOT EVEN OPEN- SO THERE IS
NO TRADING THERE IS NO VALUE ON
THESE HOLDINGS IN SOME CASES-
GROCERY STORE CHAIN THAT BANK-
AND NICKEL PRODUCER- SO IN MANY
CASES THERE'S JUST SIMPLY NO
MARKET. TO LIQUIDATE YOUR
HOLDINGS OR EVEN FIGURE OUT THE
VALUE- WHEN THE RUSSIAN MARKET
WAS OPEN THEY HAD FROZEN TRADING
ON ANY FOREIGN ORDERS AND ONLY
ALLOW DOMESTIC TRAINING TRADING
THAT WAS- FRIDAY I THINK
FEBRUARY. MISTAKE TWENTY FOURTH
OR TWENTY FIFTH BUT SINCE THEN
IT'S NOT BEEN OPENED SO THERE'S
JUST- THE HOLDINGS THAT WE BOTH
HAVE AT THIS POINT- BASICALLY
FROZEN. WE LIQUIDATE THEM IF
THERE WAS A MARKET THAT WOULD
OPEN UP- BETTER PRESENT THERE
THERE'S NOBODY TRADING ANYTHING
. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
ELABORATION I MISS YOU I GUESS
SO THE MORE SIMPLE TERMS THERE'S
NO WAY TO GET RUSSIA TO PAY OUT.
ANY KIND OF INVESTMENT RIGHT I
HAVEN'T THAT'S WHY I'M
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOU'RE
TELLING ME. WELL WHAT WE OWN IS
SECURITIES OF RUSSIAN COMPANIES-
THE YOU CAN'T SELL THE STOCK
BECAUSE- THE MARKET'S NOT OPEN-
WE ONLY OWN ONE BOND THAT THAT
WILL PROBABLY GOING TO FALL
TODAY RUSSIA IS TO PAY INTEREST
ON. THAT TODAY- THE POP GROUP.
RUBLES IF THEY PASS AND- YOU
CAN'T TRADE THEIR CURRENCY
EITHER SO- ALL THE SECURITIES
ARE JUST AT THAT POINT HELD-
FROZEN. THANK YOU. MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- GOOD SEE
YOU GUYS AGAIN WE HAD A HEARING
LAST WEEK A JOINT HEARING WITH-
SENATE PERSON ASSEMBLY PERS- WE
NOTIFIED SIX DEVELOPMENT BILLS
OVER THE YEARS AND THEY'VE
RESULTED IN ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
CHANGING STATUS QUO RESOLUTELY
DIFFERENT I KNOW THAT CALPERS
HAS POINT. 8% INVESTMENTS IN FOR
CAL STIRS ITS POINT 005% SO
OVERALL NOT A LOT OF BIG
INVESTMENTS CORRECT GERMAN.
EXACTLY RIGHT SO IT SOME POINT I
WAS THE- AND IF YOU'RE BOARD YOU
GUYS ARE WORKING ON YOUR OWN
SYSTEM THAT TOGETHER EVENTUALLY
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS.
OBVIOUSLY LEGISLATION EVERY YEAR
WE SEE FOUR FIVE BILLS ON THE
VESTMENT WHETHER IT'S TURKEY-
ARMENIA. RUSSIA CHINA. ISRAEL IT
MEANS WE'VE A LOT MORE- COMING
UP SO. IT'S FAR AS YOUR
EXPERIENCE WHAT WORKS BEST THE
LEGISLATURE PASSING LEGISLATION
ON THIS- THE INTRODUCED HIMSELF
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS WORKING ON
BACKING OUT THOSE INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER I WE DID FIND WILL LAST
WEEK'S HEARING A VERY FRUITFUL
AND THAT CERTAINLY- THE
DISCUSSIONS WORTH- ANY MEMBERS
GOING BACK AND WATCHING OUT WE
DO YOU ENGAGING WITH COMPANIES
AS MUCH MORE FRUITFUL THAN JUST
DROPPING ALL OF OUR- OUR
HOLDINGS OF A PARTICULAR COMPANY
THAT. AS SOON AS WE SELL OFF.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA CARE WHAT WE
THINK HOWEVER PARTICULARLY IN
THE FOSSIL FUEL ARENA I WE'VE-
HAD VERY LARGE SUCCESSES THAT WE
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK IN TERMS OF
THAT. ENGAGING WITH- THOSE TYPE
OF COMPANIES GETTING THEM ON A
PATH TO NET ZERO OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL DECADES AND SO THAT- IS
THE PREFERRED PATH FOR CALPERS-
AS OPPOSED TO A BLANKET
DIVESTMENT THAT BEING SAD WE ARE
CERTAIN KEY ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS
THE LEGISLATURE CAN HELP- THE
PENSION SYSTEMS. INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SORT OF MORE-
GREEN OPPORTUNITIES- GOING
FORWARD SO I WERE HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS INTERNALLY- AS A
RESULT OF YOUR HEARING ANDI
WILL CERTAINLY ACT SWING BACK-
TO THE- LEGISLATURE. WENT WHEN
WE HAVE SOME MORE CONCRETE-
IDEAS IN TERMS OF HOW YOU CAN
HELP. GET US TO WHERE WE WANT TO
BE. ALL RIGHT MY NAME'S AGAIN
CHRIS HILLMAN THANK YOU- CENTER
COOPER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AGAIN- THESE ARE TRUST
FUNDS AND WE'RE BOTH VERY
DILIGENT ON OUR BOARDS ARE HELD
TO VERY HIGH FIDUCIARY STANDARDS
TO MANAGE THESE TRUST FUNDS.
WERE VERY AGGRESSIVE IN PAYING
ATTENTION TO- AS I SAID BAYERN
MENTAL SOCIAL AND GOVERNANCE
RISK. I UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATURE'S DESIRE TO EXPRESS
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. CHALLENGE
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT LAWS ARE SLOW
TO BE ENACTED AND THEN SLOW TO
CHANGE AND THESE FINANCIAL
MARKETS ARE VERY FLUID. THANK
COMPANIES AND COUNTRIES TO
CHANGE BEHAVIOR OVER TIME WHICH
MAKES IT TOUGH TO INTERACT WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT LAW SO. NOT
SURPRISING OUR PREFERENCE WOULD
BE TO EXPRESS LEGISLATIVE INTENT
BUT ALL OF OUR BOARDS TO BE HELD
AT THEIR FIDUCIARY DUTY IN TO
TAKE ACTION. LEGISLATURE REQUEST
MANY NUMEROUS REPORTS FROM US
WHICH WE WILL PROVIDE- DID
SEVERAL TIMES. OVER AND TRY TO
GIVE YOU INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
PORTFOLIOS. SAID AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING. DESIRING ABOUT SOCIAL
CHANGE IS TOUGH BECAUSE WE'RE
INVESTMENT PEOPLE WE HAVE TO
SOLVE THIS MONTH FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT. WITH THE FACT IT'S
ACTUAL LAWS OR DIRECT WORKING
LOTS ON COMPANIES THAT WILL
BRING ABOUT THAT SOCIAL CHANGE.
SO IT'S A COMPLICATED SITUATION
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT OUR
PREFERENCE AND YOU'LL SEE THE
BOARDS TAKE POSITIONS GENERALLY
SADLY OPPOSING LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE THE BOARD WANTED TO IT
THEMSELVES. IN BIGGEST FOR ME IS
WE HAVE IN PLACE IN THIS ROOM
RIGHT NOW CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
NOT FULLY FUNDED. AND HAVE BEEN
FOR QUITE SOME TIME THEY'VE
THEY'VE GOTTEN A LITTLE BIT
BETTER THOUGH BUT- WE HAVE
RETIREES AND KERN EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE GUARANTEED A PENSION WHEN
THEY RETIRE. AND IF FOR MUCKING
AROUND WITH THIS THAT DOESN'T
HELP THEM AN EXETER THE PENSION
SYSTEMS ARE UNDERFUNDED RIGHT
NOW FEE WE'RE DUE TO MEET ALL
THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO IT IT COULD
NOT. BECAUSE NOT SUFFICIENT
FUNDS IN THERE AND WE'VE LOST
TENS OF BILLIONS THROUGH
DIVESTMENT. OVER THE YEARS YOU
KNOW JUST LIKE. CHARACTERS IT
WILL AGAINST IN WHAT THAT.
PEOPLE STILL BUY GUNS. SOME
BILLS PICKED UP SOMEWHERE SO YOU
KNOW AND I RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE A BIG ON THE FOSSIL
FUELS. AND THE MEDIAN AGE OF CAR
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
SO WELL FOLKS ARE DRIVING CARS
THAT DEPEND UPON GAS AND CAN
FORTY V. STILL. I THINK GASOLINE
IS HERE TO BE HERE FOR A WHILE.
AND PRICES ARE HIGH FOR
EVERYTHING SO. IT'S JUST ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT YOU NOW WE
SEE PEOPLE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW THEY WANT
TO DO WITH FOSSIL FUELS BUT- THE
ALTERNATIVE RIGHT NOW DOESN'T
HELP. AND CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL
MUSIC MOVE AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS BUT THE REALITY IS YOU
CAN'T FLIP A SWITCH AND DO
OVERNIGHT SO- JUST MY CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER IF NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA.
QUICKLY DO ROLL CALL MISTER LIKE
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KOREA HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS AREA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. THANK YOU AT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ADDRESSING THE
STATE'S RETIREMENT LIABILITIES
FOR THIS PORTION OF THE
PRESENTATION WE WILL HEAR AN
UPDATE ON THE ESTIMATED STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER PROP TWO AND
THE CAL STARS FUNDING PLAN WE
WILL ALSO RECEIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS TO FURTHER REDUCE THE
STATE'S RETIREMENT LIABILITIES
THERE ARE SEVERAL FOLKS ON OUR
PANELISTS BEGIN WITH MISTER ART
MARTINEZ DIRECTOR OF FINANCIAL
PLANNING AND REPORTING FOR
CASTERS. ARE THE MONARCH.
ACTUALLY DAVID LAMBERT WAS GOING
TO BE HERE ON BEHALF OF A
CASTERS 2% LET'S ACTUALLY MY
APOLOGIES LET'S START WITH-
CALPERS PROPOSALS WHICH WILL BE
PRESENTED BY ASTON CTENOPHORES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AFTERNOON THAT'S A TOUGH. OF
FINANCE. WILL BE FINE IF WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU CAN YOU SPEAK
LOUDER INTO YOUR MICROPHONE
PLEASE. ABSOLUTELY- IT. I'LL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
HIGHLIGHTING THE CALPERS BUDGET
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
ITEMS AND THEN DEVELOP QUESTIONS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES EIGHT POINT FOUR
BILLION OR FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION GENERAL FUND THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED ANNUAL
STATE CONTRIBUTION TO CALPERS
FOR THE STATE PENSION COSTS
WHICH INCLUDE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY SIXMILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
RETIREMENT COSTS. THE BUDGET
ALSO REFLECTS THREE POINT NINE
BILLION IN CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED OPPOSITION TO DEBT
REPAYMENT FUNDING WHICH INCLUDES
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION TO
FURTHER REDUCE THE STATE'S
CALPERS UNFUNDED LIABILITY AS
WELL AS THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF THE STATE OR
CONTRIBUTION TO OTHER POST
EMPLOYMENT. BENEFITS ALSO KNOWN
AS- THE SURPLUS MONEY. FUND LOAN
REPAYMENT OF FIFTY SIX BILLION
IS ALSO INCLUDED IN THE TOTAL
PROPOSITION TO. THAT INCLUDES
STATE HAVING TO TAKE QUITE OR TO
PASS ON TO MY COLLEAGUE CUSTER'S
. THANK YOU LET'S CONTINUE WITH
CAL STIRS WHICH WILL BE
PRESENTED BY RYAN WEINBERG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LEVINE WEINBERG DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THE STATE BUDGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
INCLUDES TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE COW STILL
THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
WE NOTICED IS NOT INCLUDE ANY
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
ORDER A PROJECTED INCREASE THE
STATE CONTRIBUTION RATE IN
BUDGET YEAR. THIS IS DUE TO THE
INVEST MOTEL IN THE COSTUMES
RECEIVED IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH NOW PUTS THE STATE ON
TRACK TO ELIMINATE IT SHALL BE
UNFUNDED ACTUARIAL OBLIGATION BY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. AND SO AT THIS TIME- WE
ARE NOT IT INTOSPENDING ANY
METHODS TO INCREASE THE STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS GOING FORWARD IN
THE BUDGET. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE TO GET.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO LOCAL THE FINAL APOLOGIES
YOU BOTH JUST PRESENTED L. A-
PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE INFLUENCE COURT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND A FEW BRIEF COMMENT-
REGARDING CHARACTERS YOU ARE
SUCH A CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT ARE
DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA. WE'VE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS- THE
BUDGET TRANSPARENCY PROPOSAL IS
A NO COST PROPOSAL SIMPLY TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AROUND
CULTURE SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY.
THE SECOND FOR OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT AND MANAGEMENT RESOURCES
INTO LINE WITH CHARACTERS MULTI
YEAR STRATEGIC PLAN- INCLUDING
IMPLEMENTING. THE COLLABORATIVE
MODEL. HE MADE A- PROPOSITION TO
THAT PROPOSE. THAT'S GRABBED ON
HIS TWELVE AND- OF YOUR AGENDA-
WE DO FIND THAT THE PROPOSAL
USED PROPOSITION TO FUNDING TO
MAKE A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO
CALPERS IS REASONABLE. ALTHOUGH
WE KNOW THERE ARE OTHER-
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES THAT OFF
THAT WOULD BE REASONABLE
OPTIONS. FOR THE REQUIRED
PROPOSITION TWO DEBT PAYMENTS.
WHEN I FINALLY AS DESCRIBED ON
PAGES THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA WE READ THE NUMBER
OF OTHER POINTS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERATION ABOUT
RETIREMENT LIABILITIES I WON'T
OPEN THOSE IN DETAIL THEY ARE
OUT DESCRIBED FULLY IN YOUR
AGENDA. BUT MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS ARE.
FROM THEM OF THE- NOW SEEING
NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
OUR SECOND ISSUE WILL BE A
REQUEST BY CALVET FOR ADDITIONAL
STAFF SUPPORT FOR ITS VETERAN
HOMES. LEGAL AFFAIRS
ADMINISTRATION AND
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISIONS. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES PLEASE
BEGIN. OKAY- AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BETH MACHINES CAN I'M
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
VETERANS HOMES FOR CALVET- ALL
THAT AND ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US
I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT OUR STAFFING
PROPOSAL. I WILL OUTLINE AT THE-
THE FULL STAFFING PROPOSAL AND
THEN DEPENDING ON ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE WORK AND IF NOT
DETAILS THAT YOU'D LIKE IF IT'S
FOR THE VETERANS HOMES DIVISION
OF COURSE I'LL SPEAK TO THAT AND
FOR OTHER DIVISIONS AS I
MENTIONED MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE
AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- PURPLE PROPOSAL WE
HAVE A PROPOSED THE ADDITION OF
TEN POSITIONS. ALL OF THE
POSITION UPGRADE ACROSS FOUR
DIVISIONS THAT CALVET. THREE OF
THEM ARE IN THE VETERANS HOMES
DIVISION THEY ARE A C. EIGHT TO
SERVE AS CHIEF OF FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT FOR THE SYSTEM OF.
VETERANS HOMES. AND INTO STAFF
POSITIONS ON OUR- SYSTEM HAD
CLINICAL OVERSIGHT TEAM ONE
WOULD BE A REGISTERED DIETITIAN.
AND UNDERSTAND ITS COMPLAINTS
COORDINATOR. FROM THERE WOULD BE
WE PROPOSE THREE POSITIONS AND
LEGAL AFFAIRS A LEGAL ANALYST
AND SENIOR LEGAL TYPIST AND AN
ATTORNEY AND AN ATTORNEY FOR.
FREE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIVISION POSITIONS PLUS THE
POSITION UPGRADE. TO EPA'S IN
CONTRACTING OF MATERIALS AND
STORE SPECIALIST AND AN UPGRADE
OF HEPA TO IN ESSENCE THEM ONE
FOR THE SB DVP PROGRAM. AND THE
LAST POSITION IN OUR PROPOSAL IS
FOR OUR COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION
AND IT'S A GRAPHICS DESIGNER. SO
THAT IS OUR PROPOSAL- WE ARE
AVAILABLE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
OR IF YOU LIKE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS WOULD BE HAPPY TO GO
INTO THAT- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
TALK WITH YOU. THANK YOU DEPUTY
SECRETARY ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I TIM WEBER OVER A FINANCED WITH
NO OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS ONE.
THANK YOU. L. L. THANK YOU BRING
STILL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE NO CONCERNS WITH
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I JUST
A QUESTION ON ON MY BALD
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IN MY COMMUNITY
WE HAVE A LOT OF IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN WAR VETERANS THAT
HAVE OFTEN IN OUR COMMUNICATION
IN THE DISTRICT WHEN WE- TRY TO
YOU KNOW PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES AS THEY FEEL
DISCONNECTED. TO RESOURCES FOR
VETERANS AND I'M CURIOUS WITH
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION WHAT IS
THAT OUT REACH LOOK LIKE- BEFORE
VETERANS OF MY GENERATION. HELLO
CARE CARILLO AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS I WON THE SEN DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR COMMUNICATIONS AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. THE ADDITION
OF THE GRAPHIC DESIGN ONE
POSITION WELL WHAT IN
PARTICULAR- ASSISTS ARE CAN I
OFFERED TO SPEAK CLOSER TO YOUR
MIKE PLEASE ARE JUST PROJECT A
LITTLE BALCONY SOME FAR AWAY.
OKAY SURE- WELL I HOPE WE CAN DO
THIS IN PERSON SOMETIME SOON
THEN. I'LL THE ADDITION OF THE
GRAPHIC DESIGN ONE POSITION THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING WOULD BE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON THE
PRODUCTION OF THE ANNUAL
REQUIRED REPORTS OF THE HOMES
MASTER PLAN. SO THIS IS THE
VETERANS HOME MASTER PLANNED AND
THEN OP FACILITY MASTER PLAN FOR
EACH OF THE EIGHT PATRONS HOMES.
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS. THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO FOCUS THE EFFORTS OF
OUR CURRENT GRAPHIC DESIGNER
THREE POSITION- BUT NO LINE THAT
WAS MORE CLOSELY WITH OUR
OUTREACH DIVISIONS THAT WOULD
KEEP PROVIDING CONTINUOUS
OUTREACH TO. ALL VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION VETERANS THAT WE SERVE.
SO THAT WOULD INCLUDE-
ADDITIONAL WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. A LOT OF THAT WORK AND
THOSE EFFORTS OF THAT UNIT
DESIGNED TO CONNECT CURRENT
SERVICE MEMBERS. AND
TRANSITIONING SERVICE MEMBERS
WITH THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY OF
CARE AS WELL AS INFORM THEM OF
THE BENEFITS AND SERVICES THAT
CALVET CAN PROVIDE THEM. EITHER
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY AT THE
STATE LEVEL OR AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO
WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH OUR
DIVISIONS FOR WOMEN VETERANS
AFFAIRS AND MINORITY VETERANS
AFFAIRS. AS HAVE BEEN INCREASED
THEIR OUTREACH EFFORTS TO-
UNDERREPRESENTED VETERANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FIFTY
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUR OUR GRAPHIC
REQUEST FOR GRAPHIC DESIGN
SUPPORT HAVE INCREASED BY ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT. SO
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY A NEED FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
OUTRAGE EFFORTS OF THE VARIOUS
UNITS WITHIN CALVET SO THAT WE
CAN REACH MORE VETERANS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I'M I IMAGINE THAT
YOU MEAN THE GRAPHICS ARE
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED FOR IS
THAT FOR LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA
OUTREACH PLANS. SO THAT
INCLUDES- GRAPHICS SUPPORT FOR
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WE
HAVE FOURTEEN FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS
ONE YOUTUBE ACCOUNT A LINCOLN
ACCOUNT TWITTER ACCOUNT AND
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNTS ARE PRETTY
BUSY. ALL THAT ALSO INCLUDES OUR
GRAPHIC DESIGN FOR. OUTREACH
EVENTS THAT WE CONDUCT AND- WHAT
WITH THOSE OUT UNITS IT INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE THE VETERANS DAY
POSTER THAT YOU HOLD ON CAN SEE
BEHIND TO MAKE WE PUT THOSE OUT.
AS WELL- AND ANY OTHER GRAPHIC
SUPPORT THAT OUR DIVISIONS MAY
REQUEST OFFERED THEIR JOB PARTS
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE VETERANS
RESOURCE BOOK WE DID HAVE TO
CONTRACT OUT THAT WORKS WITH
YOUR TYPICALLY WE PRODUCE OF NEW
VETERANS RESOURCE BOOK EXCEPT
THE PRINT. COPY BOOK ODD THAT IS
DISSEMINATED TO VETERANS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THE INCREASE IN REQUESTS FOR
GRAPHIC DESIGN WORK- WE DID HAVE
TO- CONTRACTED OUT THIS YEAR SO
HOPEFULLY IN YEARS TO COME IF WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL STAFFING. THAT
WE WANT THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE THAT IT HOUSES THAT
SEEMS TO BE AN INCREDIBLY
POPULAR AND EFFECTIVE WAY TO.
REACH MODERATES. UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AS WELL. THE YOU FOR THAT
I. I'LL BE FOR UP AT TO HAVE A
ONE ON ONE MEETING WITH ALL OF
YOU SINCE WE DO HAVE SOME. WE
HAVE A LOT OF VETERANS AND THAT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
A LOT OF LATINO MEXICAN
AMERICAN. VETERANS WHO ARE VERY
PRIDEFUL TO HAVE SERVED BUT
DON'T FEEL CONNECTED TO THE
RESOURCES THAT CURRENTLY ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND SO WE WANT
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY IN WHICH WE-
CHANGE THAT- AND ALSO IF WE CAN
GET SOME DATA FROM YOU IN TERMS
OF WHAT ARE THE REGIONS ACROSS
THE STATE IN WHICH- YOUR
RESOURCES ARE MOST UTILIZED AND
MAYBE LOOK AT THAT AS A WAY TO.
FIGURE OUT WHERE THERE ARE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO OUT REACH TO
VETERANS WHO HAVE. WHO HAVE
SERVED WHO ARE. WHO DESERVE TO
HAVE RESOURCES AND HAVE THAT
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT
ACCESS AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND SO
JUST SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WE'RE ALL- QUITE INTERESTED
INTERESTED AND I KNOW THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SPECIFICALLY AND
MY COMMUNITY. WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
TO CREATE MORE VETERAN HOUSING.
AND SO THAT'S DEFINITELY A
PRIORITY THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO. ISSUE NUMBER THREE THANK YOU
FOR THOSE THAT PARTICIPATED IN
THE SHOW NUMBER TWO- CAL THAT I.
T. RELATED PROPOSALS LET'S HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT BRIEFLY PERCENT
UNDER FIVE I. T. TECHNOLOGY
REQUESTS- WE WILL BEGIN WITH- I
SAY I'M ALL CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER WITH CALVET. IF YOU'RE
ON BOTH BEGIN. I COULD AFTERNOON
ARTISTS CAN EVER WANT TO HEAR ME
OKAY. YES PLEASE CONTINUE. ALSO
GOOD AFTERNOON SSEMBLY SURE
COCKERELL AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- PUBLIC PRESENT POP
FIVE PROJECTED MOST RELATED
PROPOSALS THAT OUR DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS HOSPITAL THE
SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. OF THE FIRST ONES
FOR- CAL THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORD PROJECT BOB THIS YEAR IS
A IS A GENERAL FUND I REQUEST I
REQUEST AGAINST GENERAL FUND FOR
HER AND WALDRON TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OFF THE
CONTINUE THROUGH OF THE
EXTERNSHIP BASE OF THE CARE
PROJECT NOSTRIL CAN YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLEARLY AND INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE PLEASE FOR
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING YOU.
IF YOU DON'T GIVE ME JUST A
SECOND LET ME TURN THIS PHONE
OFF. THIS RECORD.
HELLO HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
BETTER HOW MUCH BETTER YES.
EXCELLENCE I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
IT WAS A FAN OF THOSE RIGHT
BEHIND MY COMPUTER SLOW. OKAY SO
ARE THE FIRST STOP IS FOR OUR
CALVET ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
PROJECT. IS FOR CONTINUATION OF
THE EXECUTION PHASE. OF THE
PROJECT. THIS IS FOR. ON OF OUR
EXECUTION PHASE OF THE PROJECT
BOB THIS WONDER MIND- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THIS IS A PART OF. YOUR
OF THE PROJECT ARE YOU KNOW THE
PROJECT WAS EXECUTED WITH THE
PRIMARY VENDOR CONTRACT UP THE
SIGN IN ON. OCTOBER TWENTIETH
TWENTY. ONCE IT DEPENDS I'M BOX
TO THE YOU KNOW WE GET A SOME
PROJECT. ARE RESULT AND ARE.
RESULTING IN A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT- THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THE CONTROL AGENCIES AND
APPROVED ALL IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- SO. BUT THAT BRIEFLY
COVERS ALL THE PROPOSAL FOR CARE
OF THE SECOND ASKS FOR A NEW
TIME KEEPING TO OPERATE NOT THAT
ARE REQUESTING AN AUGMENTATION
FOR PLANNING PROCUREMENT
IMPLEMENTATION. AND ONGOING- THE
FOR OF A KIND OF KEEPING GO OUT
AND A CAR PAPER AND HAVE. BOB
THIS IS BUT IT'S HARD AGENCY.
ANALOG THE REQUEST FOR- ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND ALL ONCE
. NOT TO SEVENTY ALL LONG. BOB
PURPOSE IS FOR- I REPRESS. ALL
IT'S FOR LONG OF ONE POINT THREE
MILLION. TO OUR EXIST FUNDING
FOR READ. BOB THIS LECTURER
STATE THE OUR INITIAL TWENTY
REPRESSION A GRANT AN OFFICE-
SECOND ALL. YOU'RE GONNA CENTER
THOUSAND AND- ON THAT IS IN.
LESS WHAT BEGINNING ON OUR BAY.
OCTOBER CANNOT HARPER. BOB SO WE
BELIEVE THAT OUR DON'T
CONDITIONAL ON ONE FOOT THREE
DOLLARS ONE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND- WELL LOCAL THE- THE
OF. OFFERS SUSTAIN CAR OPERATE.
I DON'T THE FORTY BOTH FROM OKAY
FROM HER SUPPORT IS FOR THE
POSITIONS ARE TO SUPPORT
EXISTING ALL ELECTRONIC- HEALTH
RECORDS AS WELL AS HELPING TO W.
ACROSS VERY HOMES OF PROVIDE ALL
QUALITY CARE TO THE REST. OF
HONG. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
LONG. WE HAVE OUR PROPOSED. OR
TO SUPPORT SECURE OP. YEAH FOR
TO DEPOSE OCTOBER US ARM IN. OUR
PURPOSES. BUT ALL THE GOVERNOR'S
AWESOME THE CAN DOWN OF THE
THREAT ACTORS ARE ABOUT A THIRD. THIS EVER MORE PREVALENT- MORE
ACTIVE AND TOOK. I DON'T ARE
STRUGGLING OUR POSTURE TOWARDS
WHICH IS JERRY ALL THESE PLACES
NEEDED ADDITIONAL ARE YOU KNOW
WE BILL IT WAS YES CENTER. ARE
FROM PARTNER. OF ALL THOSE-
CALIFORNIA MOSTLY TO. AWESOME
SPLIT THE WILL HELP US ADDRESS.
FIND FROM THOSE ASSESSED. ON
COMPLEX. SO THAT'S UP THE
BARBARA- APPETITE QUESTION.
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM THE OF
FINE. AND WEBER BERMAN NEW
COMMENTS ANY OF THESE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU LEN. THANK YOU BROUGH
ZERO L. OKAY WITH ANY OF THE
PROPOSALS. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE JUST A
COUPLE ON MY END WHEN IS THE
ANTICIPATED COMPLETION DATE OF
THE CALVET ELECTRONICS HEALTH
RECORDS PROJECT. SO BASED ON THE
SPECIAL PRICING REPORT ONE THAT
WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR IN JUNE
THEY PUT THE COMPLETION DATE UP
TO. HARLEM AT THE END OF JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ARE
CURRENTLY WE ARE TRAILING BEHIND
BY ABOUT TWO MONTHS. ALSO THAT
SKID A COMPLETION OF THIS TIME
IS PROJECTED OUTTO BE IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WHAT
WHAT HAS COST THE ADDITIONAL TWO
MONTH DELAY. SO GREAT QUESTION
I'M SO HAPPY YOU ASKED ALSO
AFTER THE SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT
WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR. WE HAD
TO MOVE. THE IMITATION OF THE
ELECTRONIC PRESCRIBING MARTIAL
ARTS IS ONE OF THE ORDER CONNECT
UP IT ALL BECAUSE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SEVEN EIGHT NINE WHICH WAS
PASSED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
MANDATED THAT OFFER ALL OF ALL
FARM PHARMACY ORDERS ARE TO BE
OUR PRESCRIBE ELECTRONICALLY AND
FOR PHARMACIES TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE ON ELECTRONICALLY SO THE
LEGISLATIVE DUE DATE FOR THAT.
OF LOS FOUR CHANNEL YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ALSO WHEN WE REDID
OUR SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT WE
ARE SINCE THE BOOK ARE THE ROLE
CONDITION OF THE PARTICULAR
MODEL OCTOBER TO MEET THAT
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE. ARE VERY
POPULAR THAT WE SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THAT YOU PRESCRIBE
MODULE AND PUBLIC ORDER FORMS.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. AT IN ADDITION TO
THE TIME KEEPING TO IS K. T.
INTO STEPS TO ADDRESS THE TIME
KEEPING DOCUMENTATION VIOLATIONS
FOUND IN THE STATE. PERSONNEL
BOARD AUDIT. YES SOME
UNDERSTANDINGS OF THE ARM WHAT
IT MUST BE POINTED OUT-
SHORTCOMINGS IN TERMS OF
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ARE
RELATED TO- LEAVE BALANCE
CRACKING. ARE STILL CURRENTLY
ARE WERE UPDATING THOSE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES- YOU KNOW
CRISTINA OTHERS ALSO PROCEDURE.
ALL TWENTY TWO I DON'T PROCESSES
DATA ENTRY OR DATA COLLECTION
AND EVEN- ANY MEDIATION OR OUR
DATA CORRECTIONS OTHER BEFORE
ARE BELIEVE THAT YEAH YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS ASK FOR A HUG OR
TIMEKEEPING SYSTEM. ALL WILL BE
ABLE TO STREAMLINE ALL THE- ARE
BILLED BASED OFF BETWEEN
CHALAMET AND THE STATE OWES
OFFICE. WHO REALLY AUTOMATE. ARE
ALSO THAT ACTIVITY. THANK YOU
FOR THE RESPONSE IF THE ARE NO
DOES CA ARE WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE PANELISTS ON
ISSUE THREE. NOW WE ARE ON TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES ISSUE FOR WILL
COVER WILL COVER CALLIE CHARS.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROPOSED
CALIFORNIA LEADS US AN EMPLOYER
INITIATIVE WHICH AIMS TO IMPROVE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
AND STATE CIVIL SERVICE. LET'S
BEGIN. WITH OUR FIRST.
PANELISTS- JODY THE FABRIC THE
FOB. ACTUALLY IT'LL BE A TOUGH
RIGHT BERMAN OF FINANCE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL. YOUR QUESTION FOR
YOU- REQUEST INCLUDES SEVEN
POINT SIX NINE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING FORTY THREE POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA PIZZA DELICIOUS. SO
SPECIFIC EFFORTS TO BE ADDRESSED
INCLUDED ON THIS HIRING
INCREASED RESOURCES FOR DATA
ANALYSIS IN CALGARY'S UPS
UPDATES INSTEAD OF EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY ACADEMY
IN THE STATE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM ANY STATEWIDE EMPLOYEE
GET HER PROGRAM AND DIVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION STRATEGIC PLAN.
THAT WILL HELP CHILDREN'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE EQUITY
INCLUSION. STATE OPERATIONS.
ESTABLISHED THE FIRST MULTI YEAR
PRO IMPLEMENT CAL THE TONIGHT
SHOW. ARE WORKERS AND YOU HAVE
CHAIR HAPPY TO ANSWER THE
COMMITTEE'S ON THIS PROPOSAL
THIS TIME. LOL HI THIS IS NICK
SCHROEDER FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- BE AGENDA
INCLUDES OUR ANALYSIS FOR
PROPOSAL POSSIBLE NOT GOING TO
TOO MUCH DETAIL ABOUT IT WE
DON'T RAISE ANY OBJECTIONS
PROPOSAL BUT WE DO RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE- PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AS THE ADMINISTRATION
DEVELOPS IT'S- DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION ALL SINGLE WORD.
THANK YOU I YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
LEADS AS AN EMPLOYER SOUNDS LIKE
A REALLY GREAT INITIATIVE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GOALS TO
IMPROVE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. BUT AS WE HAVE
DISCOVERED IN SEVERAL HEARINGS
PROP TWO OH NINE OFTEN GETS IN
THE WAY OF US TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS. HOW HOW
WILL THIS BE IMPLEMENTED GIVEN.
THOSE RESTRICTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- PROPOSITION TWO NINE
PROVIDES THAT THE STATE NOT
USUALLY EVEN IF YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF I'M
SORRY JUDY LIVE FAVORING THE
DEPARTMENT PERSONAL
ADMINISTRATION. GALLAGHER PROP
TWO NINE PROVIDES THAT THE STATE
CANNOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OR
GRANT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
BASED ON A PROTECTED CATEGORY
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IT
CENTERS AROUND PROMOTING D. E.
R. AS YOU MENTIONED. FOR
EXAMPLE- FOLLOWING THE CURRENT
PRINCIPLES OF OUR MERIT BASED
HIRING PROCESS WE CAN ALREADY
FOCUS RECRUITMENT TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY AMONG APPLICANT POOLS.
WE CAN OFFER MENTORING WE CAN
INSURE DIVERSE HIRING PANELS WE
CAN INCREASE AWARENESS F
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS. ALL OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW WE CAN CURRENTLY DO TO
INCREASE T. E. I. WITHOUT
INTERFERING WITH PROP TO. SO
THIS THESE ARE FORTY THREE
POSITIONS AT APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR TO IMPLEMENT ANONYMOUS
HIRING TO AUTOMATICALLY REDACT
INFO THAT COULD COST BIAS DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS ON
GENDER AND RACIAL PAY EQUITY
STATEWIDE THE QUESTION ON GENDER
IS THAT OPTIONAL IN AN
APPLICATION. THE COW WOULD HOW
DO YOU COLLECT DATA ON WHAT.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT DATA
THAT YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY LEGALLY
ABLE TO ACQUIRE. YOU'RE RIGHT I
BELIEVE THAT THOSE THINGS GENDER
IN PARTICULAR I BELIEVE IS
VOLUNTEER RIGHT NOW YOU WOULD
HAVE TO VOLUNTEER THAT
INFORMATION. SO WE DON'T HAVE A
WAY TO REQUIRED PEOPLE TO REPORT
THAT. SO I HOPE THAT YOU SEE THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE IN IN
TERMS OF THE GOAL IS IMPRESSIVE
AND REALLY GREAT RIGHT IMPROVING
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION. BUT
HOW DO YOU DO THAT WHEN THERE
ARE LAWS THAT ACTUALLY DO NOT
ALLOW FOR YOU TO DO THAT. WHAT'S
THE WORKAROUND. LIKE I SAID WE
DO ASK PEOPLE TO VOLUNTARILY
REPORT THIS INFORMATION AND WE
DO FIND THAT THERE IS A HIGH
INSTANCE OF PEOPLE WHO DO REPORT
THIS AND SO WITH THE DATA THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO COLLECT. USING
THAT TO FORMULATE THE PROGRAMS
AND THINGS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACHIEVE WITH THIS. SO IF YOU ARE
ALREADY COLLECTING DATA ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS WHY DO YOU NEED
SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO CONTINUE DOING SO. WELL WE'RE
LOOKING TO COLLECT. A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DATA AND WE'RE NEEDING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF WAYS TO
COLLECT IT WE NEED DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WAYS TO ANALYZE IT WE
NEED STAFF TO DO THOSE THINGS
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF WORK TO
DISSECT THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS AND
GIVE IT SO MANY DIFFERENT
CONSIDERATIONS SO. WE DO NEED TO
COME TO YOUR AND REQUEST THESE
THINGS TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING TO REALLY BEGIN TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE IT TO. THE NEXT LEVEL SO
THAT IT'S REALLY MAKING AN
IMPACT ON P. E. I. AND HOW WILL
CAL H. R. MEASURE THE SUCCESS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEADS AS AN
EMPLOYER INITIATIVE. WHAT ARE
YOUR METRICS OF SUCCESS. WELL
THE ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
LOOKING TO ESTABLISH IS BETTER
REPORTING AND THROUGH THE BETTER
REPORTING WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT
TYPE OF DATA WILL SHOW. THAT THE
INCREASED MEASURES ARE WORKING
IN THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO APPLY THEM. BUT
WHAT ARE THE METRICS
SPECIFICALLY THERE WILL BE USED
. TO DETERMINE THE PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS AND HOW WILL KELLY
CHARGE AND IF I AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT. WELL THIS P. C. P.
CONTAINS SEVERAL DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND SETTLED EACH ONE
WILL HAVE DIFFERENT MEASURES-
BUT- IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION
RELATED TO A SPECIFIC ONE I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GO BACK AND
GET YOU THE ANSWER FOR THAT AND
GET BACK TO YOUR STAFF. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE- I APPRECIATE
THE INTENT AND WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT AND I THINK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IS RESPONSIBLE FORM
AND BEING GOOD STEWARDS OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS IT'S SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION EVERY YEAR TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW PROGRAM WITH
MAJOR COMPONENTS TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF. DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION AND I CAN ASSURE YOU I
AM THE FIRST ONE TO WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT WHICH IS WHY I
ASKED THE QUESTION A PROP TWO OH
NINE WHICH CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE AND SO IN BEING GOOD
STEWARDS OF PUBLIC DOLLARS HOW
DO WE- CREATE A PROGRAM. THAT
LEGALLY YOU'RE ONLY ABLE TO ASK
INVOLUNTARY VOLUNTARILY. FOR THE
INFORMATION. WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE I GUESS IN MANY WAYS
YOU CAN LOOK AT IT TO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING NOW IF YOU HAVE X.
NUMBER OF APPLICANTS HOW MANY OF
THOSE ACTUALLY VOLUNTEER THAT
DATA. WHAT IS THAT PERCENTAGE
LOOK LIKE. I WOULD HAVE TO GET
THE NUMBER FOR YOU I DO KNOW
THAT IT IS ACTUALLY IT'S A GOOD
RESPONSE AND LIKE I SAID I WOULD
HAVE TO GO BACK YOU WITH THE
EXACT NUMBER BUT IT IS A GOOD
RESPONSE CURRENTLY. AND- REALLY
I THINK THE- IN ORDER TO REALLY
GET STARTED ON THIS. HAVING THE
DATA IS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO TO BE ABLE TO MOVE IT
FORWARD SO. WE NEED TO REALLY
KIND OF GET STARTED WITH THESE
DIFFERENT MEANS AND WAYS TO. BUT
THIS DATA BE ABLE TO ANALYZE IT.
TO BE ABLE TO REPORT IT BACK TO
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE IF WHAT IT
IS WE WANT TO DO WILL ACHIEVE
THOSE THINGS. OKAY SO HERE'S
HERE'S SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BEFORE WE HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. I'D LIKE TO-KNOW HOW MANY APPLICANTS CALLIE
CHAR CURRENTLY HAS HAD TO DATE
WE CAN EVEN LOOK AT IT FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS. IN THE PAST WELL
TWO YEARS THE MID PANDEMIC CAN
BE CHALLENGING. SO LET'S FIGURE
THAT OUT. BUT OUT OF THE OUT OF
THE APPLICANTS HOW MANY HAVE
BEEN HIRED QUESTION ONE.
FOLLOWED BY OF THE APPLICANTS
HOW MANY SUBMITTED THE
VOLUNTARY- INFORMATION TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. AND I
WOULD YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IN THE
IN THE POSITION OF DIVERSITY
ALSO INCLUDE GENDER. AND SO I AM
I ASSUME I AND- CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG THAT THESE ARE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE CURRENTLY ASKING IN
THE APPLICATION. FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO COLLECT DATA. MADAM
CHAIR IF I COULD JUMP IN PER
SECOND I THINK THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION THAT THE DATA THAT'S
COLLECTED- IS FROM A FORM THAT
NEW HIRES FILL OUT NOT
APPLICANTS IN ITS DATA THAT ARE
COLLECTED BASED ON FEDERAL E. O.
REQUIREMENTS- AND SO THE
QUESTIONS ON THE FORM ARE BASED
ON GENDER AND IT'S ONLY MALE OR
FEMALE AND THEN THERE ARE MONEY
RACE RACE AND ETHNIC- CATEGORIES
THE EMPLOYEES MAY CHOOSE FROM.
AMONG THE BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THAT THE STATE
REPORT THIS INFORMATION TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WHAT THE
WHAT IT STRUCTURES THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE ASKED TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION- AND IT WILL
EASE CHOOSE TO NOT PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION WHICH IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT ABOUT 14% OF
EMPLOYEES DO NOT PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION- THEN THE MANAGEMENT
WILL IDENTIFY VISUALLY WHAT THE
EMPLOYEE IS GENDER AND RACE OR
ETHNICITY IS FOR PURPOSES OF
REPORTING TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO I THINK JUST
ACCEPTABLE TO CONFUSION THIS
DATA ARE NOT COLLECTED FOR
APPLICANTS COLLECTED. FROM HIRED
EMPLOYEES. OKAY SO I SOME FOR
UPS THAT CAN YOU. CAN YOU GO
BACK AND TELL ME AGAIN YOU SAID
THAT THE EMPLOYER VISUALLY THEN
MAKES ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S. GENDER RACE
ETHNICITY. CORRECT BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THAT REPORT
THE INFORMATION- THE WAY THAT
IT'S A LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO
MICROPHONE PLEASE. I'M SURE I
CAN- BASICALLY THE WAY THAT IT
WORKS IS BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THAT WE
REPORT THIS INFORMATION- THE WAY
CURRENTLY WORKS AS AN EMPLOYER
ASKED TO PROVIDE INFORMATION BUT
IF THEY DON'T. THE FORMER
EXPLICITLY SAYS ON THE FORM THAT
IF AN EMPLOYEE CHOOSES TO NOT
PROVIDING INFORMATION THAT
MANAGEMENT WILL VISUALLY
IDENTIFY THEM IN OTHER WORDS
MANAGEMENT WILL FILL OUT THE
FORM FOR THE EMPLOYEE. IN THAT
CASE THERE IS NO STATEWIDE
GUIDANCE AS FAR AS HOW
MANAGEMENT SHOULD DO THAT. AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
THERE COULD BE IMPROVEMENT FOR
GOING FORWARD UNDER THIS D. I.
PROPOSAL FOR THE ABOUT THE STATE
. SO IT'S BASICALLY A GUESSING
GAME BY MANAGEMENT. HOW DO YOU
KNOW THAT HOW DO YOU IDENTIFY
SOMEONE SIMPLICITY WITHOUT
ACTUALLY ASKING THEM. YOU AGAIN
THAT THIS IS A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT AND SO WE DO HAVE TO
MEET THAT INFORMATION REQUIRED
AND IT IS CURRENTLY A VISUAL
IDENTIFICATION I BELIEVE THAT
SOME. IT DEPARTMENTS WILL ASK
THE PEOPLE. IF THE BOX WAS NOT
CHECKED- GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AGAIN IDENTIFY
AND IF NOT THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
VISUALLY IDENTIFY BEST THAT THEY
CAN. MISTER COOPER THAT'S A LOT
FORCES RECORDED YOUR VEHICLE
STOP YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO YOU CAN
ASK PEOPLE TO GUESS THEIR
SEXUALITY WHAT RACE THEY ARE. ON
ALL VEHICLE STOPS THIS IS
TROUBLESOME. TO FIGURE THAT OUT
DIFFICULT YEAH. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE OUR TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT- COLLEAGUES ON THIS
DIET I DIDN'T KNOW I'M KIND OF
SHOCKED TO KNOW THAT MANAGEMENT
IS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
TAKE. TO MAKE A GUESSTIMATE.
MUCH LIKE LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
SOMEONE'S GENDER IDENTITY
ETHNICITY AT CETERA. DO
EMPLOYEES KNOW THAT THIS IS
THERE ANY ANY- ON THE FORM IS
THERE ANY KIND OF DISCLAIMER THE
NOTIFIES A POTENTIAL EMPLOYEE
THAT IF THEY DON'T FILL OUT THAT
FEDERAL FORM THAT MANAGEMENT
WILL ULTIMATELY. GAS YES THERE
IS. OKAY WELL THIS HAS BEEN VERY
ILLUMINATING CONVERSATION. AS A
MATTER OF FACT AT THE. WE LOST
WE LOST YOUR AUDIO. I'M SORRY
THERE'S ALSO- AN AREA WHERE WE
HAVE A- FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT FORM AND-
WE EXPLAIN IN THAT SECTION WHY
IT IS WE'RE GATHERING THE
INFORMATION WHAT IT'S USED FOR
BUT ALSO GO INTO DETAIL ABOUT
THAT SELF IDENTIFICATION AND THE
FACT THAT IF. PEOPLE DO NOT
IDENTIFY THAT WILL HAVE TO
VISUALLY IDENTIFY FOR THE. THANK
YOU IN ONE FINAL QUESTION OUT
WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION STRATEGIC
PLAN- HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE TASK FORCE. I ACTUALLY AM
NOT AWARE OF THOSE SPECIFICS
WOULD HAVE TO- PROBABLY TAKEN TO
THEN AGAIN GET BACK TO YOU. OKAY
ZAGAT A LONG LIST OF THINGS TO
GET BACK TO US ON BUT I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE THIS BASS OUT.
YEAH AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S A HUMAN RESOURCE NEED IN
GENERAL SO A CHARACTER HAS AN
INTEREST IN THIS. OVER ALL
REGARDLESS OF. A TASK FORCE OR
LEGISLATION THIS IS JUST PART OF
MODERN HUMAN RESOURCES SO THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN ANY. AND I'LL JUST
PUT THIS OUT THERE BUT IS THERE
A SPECIFIC REASON AND I'M NOT
SURE WHO CAN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION PERHAPS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS THERE A SPECIFIC
REASON THAT THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE DID
NOT PUBLICLY RELEASED THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS. BACKGROUND PART
OF THE FINANCE. WHERE. OKAY WELL
THEN SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF HOMEWORK TO DO I'D LIKE
TO SEE WHAT THE RECOMMENDED WHAT
THE FULL RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
DIVERSITY EQUITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION STRATEGIC PLAN HAVE
BEEN IN AN EFFORT TO. FIGURE OUT
SEVEN POINT FIVE SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION EVERY YEAR TO IMPLEMENT-
THESE MAJOR COMPONENTS. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU
TO THE PANELISTS ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. FOR THIS NEXT ISSUE WE
WILL HEAR THREE PROPOSALS FOR
CALLIE CHAR INCLUDING AN
ASSESSMENT FOR A STATE LEARNING
AND DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM VARIOUS
STAFF AUGMENTATIONS. AND CHANGES
TO CALLIE CHARTS FUNDING FOR
SPECIFIC SERVICES. LET'S BEGIN.
TURN AROUND PART OF THE
FINANCING GOING BUT IT RECOVERED
VIEW OF THESE TWO PROPOSALS.
PLEASE TAKE MY DINING
DEVELOPMENT ASSESSMENT REQUEST
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO CONDUCT A REVIEW
AND ANALYSIS OF ALL LEARNING AND
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS. THIS WAS
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A STATE
WIDE LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGY. DEPARTMENT WORKLOAD
INCLUDES SIX POINT THREE MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOUR
POINT NINE I'M GOING AND TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE POSITIONS TO
INCREASE RESOURCES FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE LEGAL AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WORKLOAD
. DRESS INFANTS SAVINGS PLUS
PROGRAM COSTS IS LOOKING TO JUST
ESTABLISH REMEMBER THE PENDANT
REPAIR EDUCATION. THE PROPOSAL
IS A FUNDING HOPE REALIGNMENT
THAT REQUESTED APPROXIMATELY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENTOR AN EQUIVALENT
THREE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR STATE WIDE CONTROL.
RELATED WORK WHAT. FUNDING WILL
SUPPORT GAS RIGHTS AS WELL AS
THE SELECTION DIVISION. AND THE
PERCENTAGE YOU CAN ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE COMMITTEE'S ON THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALEJO.
SORRY AN EXTRUDER AGAIN FROM THE
L. A- WE DON'T HAVE ANY- ISSUES
WITH MEDIA PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE DIVES. SEEN NONE
JUST A COUPLE ON MY END WHEN
DOES KELLY CHARLESTON MADE
COMPLETING THE STATEWIDE
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ASSESSMENT SHOULD THE RESOURCES
FOR A VENDOR BE GRANTED. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE COCHRAN FROM
COLLEGE ARE. THOSE REQUIREMENTS
ARE THOSE THOSE WILL BE
COMPLETED WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR.
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR COULD BE
DOING COULD BE DECEMBER WHEN
SPECIFICALLY. WITHIN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR STUBBLE BEFORE JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR GOT IT THANK YOU
HELLO KELLY CHARRING GAUGE WITH
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO USE SERVICES THAT WOULD
NO LONGER REQUIRE REIMBURSEMENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION-
WE WERE GONNA HAVE TO WORK WITH
YOU TO GET STAFF- CHANCE WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. OKAY SO MUCH LIKE
ISSUE FOR AN ISSUE FIVE WE ARE
WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE ANSWERS
TO SOME OF THE PROPOSAL IDEAS.
SORRY WE CAN HEAR YOU I THINK
YOU'RE ON MUTE. WE APOLOGIZE-%
YES WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU AS-
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE OKAY CAN WE
SET A DATE AS TO WHEN YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO US SINCE
WE HAVE TO VOTE ON THE BUDGET.
WE SHOULD HAVE THE ANSWER TO YOU
FOR THIS PARTICULAR. ISSUE BUT
AT THE END OF THE WEEK. GREAT
THANK YOU. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE CAN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE PANELISTS
ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE- WE'RE
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY THE
CPPA IS A NEW STATE ENTITY THAT
WAS CREATED AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
PROP TWENTY FOUR NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THIS NEW AND
AGENCY WILL BE TASKED WITH
ENFORCING CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL
PRIVACY LAWS TODAY THE AGENCY IS
PRESENTING A REQUEST FOR INITIAL
STAFFING RESOURCES. LET'S BEGIN. APRIL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE HAVING TO ALL THE
PANELISTS MOVING FORWARD AT
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF-
AUDIO DIFFICULTY SO YOU ALL
SOUND KIND OF FAR AWAY IF YOU
CAN JUST PROJECT YOUR VOICE INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE THAT BE GREAT
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY ONE OF THE
CHECK IS THIS OKAY. YES PLEASE
CONTINUE. PERFECT THANKS MY NAME
IS ASKS WHAT'S FUNNY AND THEY'RE
NOT NARAL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED PIPES
PROTECTION AGENCY BUT IT'S NOT
FIRST TIME IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE I THOUGHT I PROVIDE A
BIT MORE BACKGROUND ABOUT. OUR
AGENCY. SO I JUST AS YOU
MENTIONED OUR AGENCY WAS CREATED
AFTER VOTERS APPROVED PROP
TWENTY FOUR. AND SPECIFICALLY
THE- BETTER OPPOSITION AMENDS
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND GRANTS CONSUMERS RIGHTS WITH
REGARDS TO THE MEETING- AND
CONTROLLING THE INFORMATION THAT
BUSINESSES COLLECT. ABOUT. THE
CITY PAPER CALIFORNIA'S BY.
OBLIGATE ON SIR BUSINESSES.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE HAVE- OVER
TWENTY MILLION IN GROSS REVENUE.
SERVICE ITSELF SHARE PERSONAL
COMMERCIAL ON A HUNDRED THOUSAND
OR MORE CALIFORNIANS FOR THOSE
THAT DERIVE 50% OR MORE OF THEIR
ANNUAL REVENUE FROM THE SEVEN OR
SHARING ABOUT INFORMATION.
DISPATCHER PROGRAMS FOR THE
GENERAL FUND FIVE MILLION. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TEN MILLION. PER FISCAL
YEAR THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT THE
OPERATION OF OUR AGENCY. OR
OPERATION CAN BE BROKEN DOWN
INTO THREE KEY AREAS- WILL
MAKING ADMINISTRATIVE BEFORE
SPENT WHICH IS SET TO BEGIN JULY
OF NEXT YEAR. AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND OUTREACH
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS UNDERSTAND ARRESTS
AT RESPONSIBILITIES SURROUNDING
THE COLLECTION USE. AND
DISCLOSURE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THE BOARD WAS A
POOR MAR OF LAST YEAR DURING THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF A
SUBSTANTIAL HELP IN THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES OF HOUSING
AGENCY. THE WE GET THEIR UP THE
INCLUDING SAID UP HE
ADMINISTERED FIX CONCERNS
FISCALE. STATE CONTROLLERS OFF.
HIRING PURCHASING AUTHORITY BY A
DOES THAT DEPARTMENT SERVICES
AND I CHIEF. THE BOARD CENTER IN
ARCHITECT BALL FARM AND IN.
ADDITION SETTING UP A PHYSICAL.
OFFICE SOMETIME IN THE CREATION
OF PENDANT. IN ADDITION TO
ESTABLISH AN AGENCY THE BOARD-
ALSO BY AND AGENCIES SUBSTANTIVE
WORK. IN PREPARATION FOR FORMAL
RIGHT WELL MY- IT SIX. PROGRAM
WILL MAKE ACTIVE. IN
INTERPRETATION FOR COMMENTS AND
- BEGINNING WORK ON SPECIFIC
WILL MAKE. TOPICS THE BOARD ME
AS THE OF DR OF LAST YEAR I HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON OFF TO. I STATUS
STUDENTS YOU. SOMEONE TO
ACTUALLY TO. FUNCTION RULEMAKING
PROMOTING WHEN. FIRST MINISTER
PARTY WITH THE STREET THE
PROCESS OF CONTROL AGENCY AS A
SIDE WE DON'T YET HAVE A OWN FOR
FIVE. ARE CHAPTER TWO RULEMAKING
WE ALSO NOT THE GENERAL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I MEAN THE ACT
BY THE POINT. WE ARE BEGINNING
TO BUT WE ARE PREPARED BEGIN
WITH MAKING. IT FOR THAT WILL
MAKING TRY SO AGENCIES ONE AFTER
STUDY OF THIS X. MONTH. THE
BOARD NOW SO PUT YOUR
ADDITIONALLY FROM. TO ASSIST
WORKABLE A BUT IN THE STATURE
AND ARTICLE. LEGAL SERVICES AND
THE MINISTRY OF. AND WE'RE
WORKING THE NIGHT HOW PAGES OF
CALM WHICH AS PART OF OUR-
AMERICAN ACTIVITIES. RBC PEER
THIRTY FOUR PRISON IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. I'M GOING TO
ENABLE US TO SATISFY YOUR
INITIAL STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
WITH A FOCUS ON WAR MAKING AND
PUBLIC AWARENESS. NATIONAL STOCK
IT WAS BASED ON THE AMERICAN
CONSTITUTIONAL OTHER STATE
AGENCIES WITH SIMILAR SIZE
ADMISSION AS OURS. AT NOTE THAT
THIS REQUEST DOESN'T REFLECT A
FULL COMPLEMENT OF STAFF
EQUIPMENT DOESN'T INCLUDE ARMED
FORCE INTERVENTION OPTION ONLY
AS I SAID BEGINS IN JULY OF NEXT
YEAR. NORTH THE FULL ROSTER
MINISTRY TO STOP HIS WORK
CHRONICLELIVE ON OUTSOURCED
SERVICES FOR HIRING CONTRACTING. PURCHASING AND I KEEP. URGENCY
GROWS FIND A WAY WITH THEM AND
TO ENOUGH OVERSTAFFED AT RISK A
PRO IS GOOD FOR THAT STUFF. AND
HOW. IT WILL BEGIN YOU'LL THAT
WAS CHEN FUND APART. APPROPRIATE
BY TWENTY. APPROVAL P. C. P.
MORE HELP US IN LETTING US FROM
HIRE THE KEY FROM. THE ARE
AGENCY DESPERATELY NEED. I LOOK
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
LET'S HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF. AND YOUR HEART DEPLOYMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. L. L.
THREE MINUTES CURLY- WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MISTER
COOPER. CHURNS FOR THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WHAT'S THE DEADLINE TO
ADOPT THEIR PRIVACY REGULATIONS
. THAT DARK DEADLINES SET FORTH
IN THE STATUTE IS SET FOR JULY
TWENTY TWENTY CAN I DRIVE CAN I
ASK YOU TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
LOUDER INTO YOUR MIKE PLEASE. IS
THAT FOR ME. BUT THAT'S JUST A
FEW MONTHS AWAY SO WHAT STEPS TO
BE COMPLETED IN THE PROCESS FOR
ADOPTING PRIVACY REGULATIONS.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS I MENTIONED
THE BOARD ENGAGED PRIOR TO MY
APPOINTMENT AND SUBSTANTIVE
OPERATOR ACTIVITIES THAT
INCLUDED IT. COMMENTS OR WHICH
WOULD RECEIVE SOMETHING LIKE
NINE HUNDRED PAGES OF COMMENTS
FROM CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
STAKEHOLDERS WE'RE ALSO PLANNING
TO ANNOUNCE AT THE END OF THIS
WEEK. A SET OF- INFORMATIONAL
WORKSHOPS AND STAKEHOLDER IN
ADVANCE OF A FORMAL RULEMAKING
AND SO THAT WHICH IT ANNOUNCED
AT THIS WEEK THOSE WILL OCCUR
LATER THIS MONTH AND EARLYNEXT
MONTH OVERSIGHT MID NEXT MONTH-
WE ARE. HAS A ANNOUNCEMENT BOARD
MEET- PLANNED TO PUT OUT A DRAFT
RULES AND CHU CHU OF THIS YEAR.
WHICH ARE THE EXPECTED
COMPLETING COMPLETION DATE OF Q.
THREE Q. FOUR. AND WE THOUGHT
THAT THIS WOULD ESSENTIALLY-
PROVIDE THE RIGHT BALANCE. IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO- ENGAGE
AND RECEIVE STAKEHOLDER INPUT
AND ALSO SATISFY OUR.
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LAW. SO
WHAT STEPS REMAINING THEN. SO
WE'RE IN THE IN THE PROCESS OF
RECEIVING ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK
FROM- STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
EXPERT INPUT AND DRAFTING OUR
OUR INITIAL GRAPPLES I WHICH
POINT WE WILL THEN PUT OUT OUR
INITIAL INDICATIONS ARE FORMAL
RULEMAKING- DRAFT PATTERNS ARE
BEGINNING A BILL MAKING PROCESS
SEVEN. THAT'S RIGHT FOR WHICH
THAT IS GOVERNED BY THE- OF THE
WILL MAKING PROCESS IN THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW SO
YOU NEVER HAD THAT JULY FIRST
DEADLINE THE CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY HOW MANY STAFF DO
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE AND ONE OF
THE POSITIONS. WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
STAFF CURRENTLY WE HAVE IN
ADDITION TO ME WE HAVE A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATION WE
HAVE- SEVEN I WOULD JUST PUT OUT
AN AWFUL FOR. SHAR STOP-
WHICHEVER HR LIAISON WHICH WILL
HELP US. A HIGHER MORE QUICKLY
AND THEN WE HAVE. SOME HIGH NAY
GPA WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF THE
KIND OF STAFF ON MON WE HAVE.
ARE ACTING GENERAL COUNSEL WHICH
IS A RETIRED NORTON FORMERLY THE
CHIEF COUNSEL OF DMB AND HE DID
THE ROLE MAKING FOR THE
ECONOMIST VEHICLE REGULATIONS SO
HE'S QUITE ADEPT AT THESE
COMPLEX ROLES WE ALSO HAVE A
NUMBER OF STAFF SUPPORT. FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THEIR
NATIONAL TEAM THAT HELPED CREATE
THE RULES WHICH YOU SEE PA AND
THAT'S AS AS CONTEMPLATED THE
STATUTE THAT STAFF IS ACTUALLY
WORKING VERY ACTIVELY IN
SUPPORTING. THE BOARD FINALLY%
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY UNIQUE BUT
OUR BOARD AND SOME TO SOME
DEGREE- ACTING AS STAFF THE
BOARD. ATTRACTIVELY BROKEN GOING
TO TREAT MEMBER SUBCOMMITTEES TO
LOOK FOR AND IDENTIFY KEY ISSUES
FOR MAKING AN TO HELP INFORM
THAT WILL MAKING SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE A LOT MORE QUICKLY I
REALIZE THAT'S UNIQUE AWARE
STARTING FROM SCRATCH AND REALLY
TRYING TO. TO THIS- GET THESE
THINGS RIGHT. THE BC S. FOR
THIRTY FOUR WAS. WHAT SIXTY
TIMELY TO A THE STAR FOOT WAS.
JUST KNOWING WHAT THE CLIMATE IS
STATE. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
YOU KNOW WE ARE ARE WE VISIONS
THAT- WILL. WELL SO I'M WORKING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO BRING
ON OUR KEY EXECUTIVE STAFF AND
WITH THE ADDITION OF THAT
EXECUTIVE STOCKS THAT EACH OF
THE DIVISION LEAD SO WE HAVE A
LEGAL AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND
POLICY DIRECTOR POSITIONS BUT UP
CLOSE OR IN THE PROCESS OF.
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS FOR THOSE
POSITIONS WHICH WE HOPE TO SOON
HIRE IN THE NEXT MONTH OR TWO
ONE SO KEEP THIS IS ARE HIRED
AND WITH THE ADDITION OF THE HR
LIAISON WE HOPE TO THEN BE ABLE
TO MORE RAPIDLY HIGHER FOR ALL
OF THE COURT. ACTIONS OF THOSE
DIVISIONS FOR EXAMPLE JUST TODAY
WE PUT OUT- POSTED FOR PORTRAIT
INNOVATIONS WHICH WILL
CONSTITUTE OUR CORE LEGAL
DIVISION SEPARATE FROM
PORTSMOUTH BUT OUR LEGAL
DIVISION THAT WILL HELP INFORM
BOTH THE RULE MAKING AS WELL AS
THE OTHER LEGAL FUNCTIONS OF THE
AGENCY I EXPECT THAT BEING THAT
CLOSE COURT STAFF. WILL BEGIN TO
THE EXPONENTIALLY WHEN I'M DONE
WITH THE GOAL OF OUR THIRTY FOUR
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR THIS
CALENDAR YEAR ENDING AGAIN I
EXPECT TO COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH UPDATED BCPS
HOUSE WITHOUT A FIGURE OUT WHAT
KEY STAFF AND WHAT CAN WE NEED
BOTH. FOX SPORTS AND FUNCTION AS
WELL AS AS WE TRANSITION
SERVICES FROM FEES HOSTED
MANAGED SERVICES DID YOU ASK
INTO IN HOUSE SERVICES FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN WE RECEIVE OUR
HIRING OR FORTY OR DIRECT HIRING
AUTHORITY AND PARTICIPANTE I
WOULD EXPECT WE WOULD NEED
SUBSTANTIVELY MORE STAFF TO
SUPPORT THAT FUNCTION IN HOUSES
RIGHT NOW IT'S CURRENTLY BEING
MANAGED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. DOES THE
AGENCY MORE TIME TO COMPLETE.
THE ADOPTION OF PRIVACY
REGULATIONS. SO AS I SAID IN MY-
MY EARLIER REMARKS. WE HI
INDICATED KERN WILL MAKE-
CALENDAR. TO DOUBLE UP FROM.
SEVENTEENTH BOARD MEETING AND
BOARD VICE VERSA. SUPPORT OF THE
- TIMELINE OF THE STRIKES RIGHT
BY BETWEEN. THE COMMISSION
GATHER AND SUPPORTING- THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE AGENCY. I
DON'T THINK THE BORDERS TAKING A
POSITION ON. WHETHER WE NEED ANY
CHANGES TO THE TIMELINE OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT WE AS I
SAID. PLANK HAVE DROPPED SCHOOLS
INTO PLACE. FOR CAPITALS IN CHIU
AND COMPLETE OUR WILL MAKING. BY
Q. THREE Q. FOUR. I JUST I HAVE
SOME. ABOUT YOU GUYS BEING YOUR
DE IT'S JUST THERE'S A LOT OF
ALL IN THE AIR GET IT GOING
THERE LIKE I SAID. IN THE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A LOT OF
OPENINGS THE STATE IS A LOT OF
OPENINGS EVERYONE DOES IT IS
TOUGH TO HIGHER THESE DAYS I
THINK THAT. YOUR GOAL OF HURDLES
FULTON GETTING ON BOARD BUT IN
THE YEAR. MIGHT BE SOMEWHAT
AMBITIOUS. I THINK THAT'S RIGHT
IT IS INDEED AND DISHES. AND A
BUSINESS PLAN. I WILL SAY THAT
I. THE STAFF. NECESSARY FOR THE
ROLE MAKING ARE NECESSARILY THE
THIRTY FOR A LOT OF THOSE.
THIRTY FOUR R. TO COMPLETELY.
KEY FUNCTIONS LIKE. FOR EXAMPLE-
THE- POLICY FOR EXAMPLE WRITING
IBCP WHICH I HAD TO. LEARN TO
DO. PROJECTS THIS YEAR- AND- AN
INCLUDING I KEEP. KEEP OR- CHUNK
ABOUT HEAD COUNT IS ALSO FOR
PUBLIC AWARENESS FUNCTION.
DISPATCHING DIRECTS US IN
ADDITION TO RULE MAKING. AND
ENFORCEMENT. TO REALLY HELP.
CALIFORNIANS A DIVERSE SET OF
CALIFORNIANS. I UNDERSTAND THIS
COMPLICATED. ISSUES AROUND
PRIVACY AND HOW TO MANAGE THEIR
PRIVACY SECURITY. SO I HOPE. TO
STAFF UP AND- SPENT A GOOD
AMOUNT OF OUR EXPERT. HELPING
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENTS. KIND OF A DIVERSE
SET OF- COMMUNICATION
STRATEGIES. SO THAT PEOPLE.
UNDERSTAND. OUR PRIVACY RIGHTS
MUST CALIFORNIA. I MOST COME
DON'T KNOW THESE RIGHT YOU GET A
- NOT OP. ABOUT OPERATES ON.
THANK YOU CAN. THANK YOU MISTER
COOK. I THINK WHAT A WHAT I
HEARD YOU SAY MR SOLTANI IS THAT
THE BOARD HAS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION TO ON WHETHER IT WILL
MEET ITS DEADLINE WHICH PUTS YOU
IN A VERY COMPLICATED SPACE AND
SO IF THE BOARD IS NOT MAKING A
DECISION. AND YOU DON'T MEET
YOUR DEADLINE THEN YOU'RE ALSO
VIOLATING THE LAW. SO DO YOU
ACTUALLY NEED MORE TIME. SO TO
CLARIFY THE BOARD HAS NOT TAKEN
A POSITION AS TO WHETHER WE NEED
TO FOR EXAMPLE EXTEND OUR
DEADLINE- WHAT I HAVE SAID IN
THE BOARD HAS SUPPORTED IS THAT
OUR RULE MAKING PANEL PACKAGE
WILL NOT BE COMPLETED WITH THAT
ARE DEADLINE WHAT WE WILL NEXT
ARE DEADLINE THAT'S WHAT I SAID
AND I LOST FOR MEETINGS AND IN
THE- SENATE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
CARRYING ON THIS ISSUE. I'M MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA DOJ ALSO DID NOT MEET
THEIR DEADLINES BUT FACE NO
ISSUE NO LEGAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
MISSING THAT DEADLINE
NECESSARILY AND MY PLAN IS AS I
SAID TO TRY TO PUT OUT THE BEST
SIDE OF BULLS AS SOON AS WE CAN
INCLUDING BY BEFORE THE DEADLINE
PUTTING A VERY WELL- KIND OF
RESEARCH AND- KIND OF- SET OF
RULES THAT HAVE. SUBSTANTIAL
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND I'M SO
THAT THOSE FIRST DRAFT RULES ARE
CLOSE TO WHERE I WILL END UP AT. THE END OF THE L. A. L.
PROCESS. DO KNOW WHY THE BOARD
HAS NOT SCHEDULED. THEIR NEXT
MEETING. IF THESE REGULATIONS
ARE SET TO BE STATUTORY DUE BY
JULY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. SO THE
BOARD IN FACT AS IF THEY WERE
PLANNING TO SCHEDULE UR NEXT
MEETING- I WILL ANNOUNCE THAT
THAT MEETING AT THE END OF THIS
WEEK. AND WILL BE SCHEDULED FOR
LATER THIS MONTH AND THE BOARD
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN MEETING QUITE
FREQUENTLY- OVER THAT OVER. THAT
THIS YOU KNOW OVER THE COURSE OF
ITS EXISTENCE OF BASED SENSE
SUMMER OF LAST YEAR IT'S NOT
SOMETHING LIKE SIX TIMES. AND
RIGHT NOW THE FACT BOARD
MEETINGS WORK I THINK COUNTERED
COUNTERTERROR WE WILL MAKE THE
CREATION OF THE RULES AS THOSE
ARE BEING DONE IN SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO THE SUBJECT MATTER
SUBCOMMITTEES ARE WORKING ON THE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLES AND THEN WE
WILL SCHEDULE AS PART OF THE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS ADDITIONAL
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
EXPERTS AND THEN WE WILL
SCHEDULE- BALANCE OF THE
ADOPTING THAT WILL MAKING
PACKAGING YOU TO A NUMBER OF
BOARD MEETINGS WHERE THE BOARD
TO REVIEW THE ACTUAL DRAFT. TEXT
PRODUCED BY SOME. COMMITTEE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH STOP. THANK YOU
MISTER. YEAH I REALLY HAVE A OR
QUESTION PER SE OTHER THAN SAY
THAT THIS IS A CLEAR SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHEN- THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS IS IN
CONFLICT WITH THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION. AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE IN THIS VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION AS WE'RE ADDRESSING
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKING I WOULD AGREE. OKAY WELL
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND WE DON'T
HAVE CERTAINTY AS TO WHEN THE
NEXT BOARD MEETING WOULD BE OR-
ACTUALLY IF. THE AGENCY WILL BE
ABLE TO MEET ITS GOAL BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT SEEMS
LIKE WE HAVE SOME UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AT THE MOMENT THAT WE
MAY HAVE TO RETURN TO. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN I WANT TO THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
WE ARE NOW ON TO GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION ONTO THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION.
WHICH IS OUR LAST ISSUE THE
COMMISSION WILL DISCUSS ITS
REQUEST FOR SUPPORT STAFFING TO
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
STATE AUDITOR. LET'S BEGIN. THE
DATE CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS STACY WHEN A BAXTER THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION IS
REQUESTING FOR ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS AND FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FOURTHOUSAND DOLLARS AND
SPECIAL FUNDS. TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS OUTLINED IN FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. AS
WELL AS STRENGTH IN OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
AND OPERATIONS. INFORMATION
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS ADDRESS
INCREASE WORKLOAD AND
IMPLEMENTED ADDITIONAL
EFFICIENCIES WITHIN THE
COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO THE COMMITTEE REGARDING THE
STATUS OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS HOWEVER IN QUICK
SUMMARY THE COMMISSION WAS
ISSUED FIVE FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. OR HAVE BEEN COMPLETED
THE REMAINING RECOMMENDATION
REQUIRE STATUTORY CHANGE WHICH
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
PURSUING DURING THE CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. I AM JOINED
TODAY BY THE COMMISSION'S DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY AFFAIRS ADRIANA CALL
UP BUT SHARA AND WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. AFTERNOON
KEVIN CLARK WITH THE PROMINENT
FINANCE AND NO FURTHER COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME. L. L. I NEED ONLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY I'VE SEEN NOT
JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION FOR ME
CAN THE COMMISSION PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE STATUS OF THE
IMPLANT OF IMPLEMENTING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
. YES OF COURSE HERE ARE- IF
YOU'D LIKE I CAN GO BY EACH
RECOMMENDATION OR JUST GIVE US A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF THOSE. A BRIEF
SUMMARY WOULD BE GREAT THANK
YOU. WONDERFUL WE HAD- LIKE I
SAID FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS FOUR
OF WHICH WERE COMPLETED AND HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED- THEY RANGE FROM
ANYWHERE FROM- TRACKING
LICENSING INFORMATION TO.
IMPLEMENTING CHANGES IN OUR
REGULATIONS TO- HAVE CONSISTENCY
AND UNIFORMITY BUT THEN OUR
LICENSE TYPES. AS WELL AS-
FORMALIZING PROCEDURAL
INFORMATION THE ONLY.
RECOMMENDATION THAT IS
CURRENTLY- ISSUED- BUT- ARSENAL
INCOMPLETE WORK PARTIAL
COMPLETION BY STATE AUDITOR IS
RELATIVE TO OUR COST IMPIAN
ALICE'S THE COMMISSION HAS DONE
ALL THE WORK THAT IT NEEDS TO DO
HOWEVER WE NEED ONE CHANGE TO GO
THROUGH STATUTORY CHANGE. WHICH
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH-
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
HOPEFULLY SECURE THE POT LAST
PIECE OF STATUTORY CHANGE THAT
WE NEED IN ORDER TO MARK THIS
RECOMMENDATION COMPLETE. THE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BACKGROUND ON GAMBLING YOU
GOT THOSE- CARS THOSE THOSE
CARDS IN THE BACK. VERY VERY ON
BRAND. THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
IF OF THAT COMPLETES OUR LAST-
OUR LAST- ISSUE THANK YOU AGAIN
TO ALL THE PANELISTS WERE GONNA
NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. AND
APOLOGIES- WE ACTUALLY HAD A
MISTER TO SYRIAN YOU HAD A
COMMENT REGARDING ISSUE ONE
APOLOGIES ON THAT BEFORE WE GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT NOT AT ALL MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
REMEMBERING- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. IF THIS IS THIS IS
SOMEWHAT UNORTHODOX BECAUSE WE
DON'T REALLY DISCUSS TOPICS ONCE
THEY'VE PASSED THEIR TIME. OF
THE HEARING BUT- SOME COMMENTS
WERE MADE BY A COLLEAGUE OF
MINE. WHO I RESPECT AND
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH AND HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS. THAT I NEEDED FELT
COMPELLED TO WANT TO CORRECT- IT
. SO FIRST OF ALL. IT ONE
OPINION WAS SAID DURING THE
DURING THE DIVESTMENT
CONVERSATION WE WERE HAVING THAT
DIVESTMENTS DON'T WORK AND
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT NATIONS WERE
LISTED. SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A DIVEST
MEANT EFFORT. TOWARDS ARMENIA OR
ISRAEL THERE'S BEEN A BDS
MOVEMENT AT SOME LOCAL LEVELS
AND AT THE PARTY LEVEL TOWARDS
ISRAEL BUT- THAT'S NEVER
MATERIALIZED INTO ANYTHING
SUBSTANTIVE- IF ANYTHING
ARMENIAN ISRAEL HAVE BOTH BEEN
OPPRESSED. UP OVER THEIR HISTORY
AND SO IT'S BEEN IMPORTANT FOR.
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
A SIZEABLE POPULATION OF BOTH
ARMENIAN AMERICANS AS WELL AS
JEWISH AMERICANS TO. ENSURE THAT
THEIR HISTORY IN. EDUCATING
ABOUT HISTORY CORRECTLY SO THAT
IT DOESN'T REPEAT ITSELF- AND
THIS WAR IS THE LATEST EXAMPLE
OF JUST WHAT HAPPENED. TWO YEARS
AGO WE SAW HOW AZERBAIJAN AND
TURKEY ATTACKED ARMENIA. AND IT
WAS THE FIRST YEAR OF A PANDEMIC
UNDER A DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION
IN THE U. S. AND- YOUDID NOT
HEAR MUCH ABOUT THAT WAR AS MUCH
AS WE'RE HEARING NOW ABOUT
UKRAINE. AND RUSSIA. OF AND PART
OF IT IS BECAUSE- THERE'S
GEOPOLITICAL AND OIL
CONSIDERATION BUT ALSO WAS THE
FIRST YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE WORLD'S INACTION
IN THAT WAR. RUSSIA SAW AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE SAME THING
NOW. AND IT'S TAKING A LONG TIME
FOR IT TO DO WHAT IT'S DOING
BECAUSE THERE'S GREATER
AWARENESS AND WORK AGAINST THAT.
AND BUT BUT UNFORTUNATELY MOST
OF THE WORLD IS STILL STANDING
IDLY BY WATCHING IT HAPPEN. AND
SECOND AS WE'VE PROGRESSED IN
CURRENT DAY WARFARE WE KNOW
THAT. ECONOMICS AND FINANCES ARE
THE BEST WAY OF CURTAILING HARM
TO HUMAN LIFE SO WHEN YOU TAKE
STEPS TO DAMAGE SOMEONE
ECONOMICALLY YOU WILL. YOU WILL
GET TO A PLACE WHERE- YOU THE
HUMAN SUFFERING. STOPS THE
BLEEDING STOPS AND SO I DO THINK
THAT- A DIVESTMENT WORKS- IT
CAN'T BE SOMETHING THAT'S DONE
ON EVERY ISSUE BUT IT'S A GREAT
FORM OF EXERCISE. TO ACTUALLY
HELP STOP HARM. RAIDER HARM FROM
HAPPENING AND IF THE DIVEST
MONTHS WE'VE PASSED THE WE'VE
HELPED PASS IN THE PAST. OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO WE PASSED THE
DEBT FIRST ADVANCEMENT WITH THE
SOUTH AFRICA AND IT HAD
REMARKABLE IMPACTS. FOR THAT
COUNTRY AND FOR. MANY PARTS OF
AFRICA AS WELL- HAD IF WE ARE
STRATEGIC. AND PRECISION
ORIENTED AND THE STEPS WE TAKE
WE ACTUALLY CAN HAVE THE
VESTMENT BE A GREAT TOOL TO
ADDRESS. A VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND OTHER PLACES
BECAUSE WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND WE HAVE
THE THIRTEENTH LARGEST BUDGET IN
THE WORLD AT THIS POINT.
IRONICALLY RUSSIA'S FOURTEENTH
AND SO WHEN WE IMPOSE OUR WILL
FINANCIALLY ON SOMEBODY ELSE IT
ACTUALLY IS REVERBERATED OVER
THE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND IT
HAS AN IMPACT SO I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS A
COUNTER ARE ARE A STATEMENT MADE
TO THAT OF THE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE KNOW WHAT OUR MIGHT IS AND
WHAT WE CAN DO AS CALIFORNIA OF-
IT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT WE WERE
STATE AND WE ARE ACTIONS.
SHOULDN'T BE ON THE
INTERNATIONAL FRONT BUT GIVEN
THE POPULATIONS THAT WE'VE
BENEFITED FROM. AS CONSTITUENTS
AND RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE AND
GIVEN OUR ECONOMIC MIGHT. I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE TWO NORTON
WORTHY- FACTORS THAT ALLOW US TO
PLAY A ROLE IN THIS SO. MANAGER
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
AT LEAST THE SAVE THOSE COUPLE
WORDS SO I THINK I GROUP MY
COLLEAGUE ON THAT. OCCASION WHEN
THE WHEN THE LIGHT OF THE WORLD
GETS INVOLVED THAT'S GOOD IT'S A
GOOD THING BUT WHAT I'M SAYING
IS ON THESE PASSED THE VESTMENTS
IT HASN'T BEEN THE LIGHT. OF THE
WORLD A LOT IT IS JUST
CALIFORNIA EARLY PEOPLE DOING
THAT AND- WE SAID THE
PERSEVERING OF THE IT WAS THE-
JOINT COMMITTEE. BETWEEN
ASSEMBLY PERSON SENATE PERS. AND
THE SIX INVESTMENTS HAVE HAD
HAVE NOT WORKED SOUTH AFRICA'S
DIFFERENT THE WORLD WAS ON THAT.
SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS I AGREE
WITH YOU. I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
BUT- IT CAN'T BE CALIFORNIA
ALONE AND RUSHED TO THE GOOD
EXAMPLE YOU HAVE THE ENTIRE
WORLD. SO CALIFORNIA MAY DO IT
IN FIFTH LARGELY CONNIE BUT THAT
SAME TIME. THERE'S SOME ISSUES
WITH THAT. YOU KNOW IT WITH
CALIFORNIA DOING IT BY ITSELF
SO. TO ME IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE
EVERYBODY COMES IN. AND WE HAVE
FOUR FIVE DIVEST BILLS EVERY
YEAR IN PERSON AND I'VE BEEN
HERE EIGHT YEARS DEALING WITH
THIS. AND LIKE FOR OVER A
VARIETY OF REASONS SO. YOU KNOW
A FEW THINGS HAVE CHANGED
ABSOLUTELY I AGREE- IT'S
ATROCIOUS WITHIN THESE FOLKS
HAVE DONE. BUT ALSO THESE BIG
PENSION SYSTEMS. CAN ALSO MOVE
IT HAVE AN EFFECT ON THEIR OWN.
IN GETTING US THERE VERSUS THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY YEAR PUTTING A
NEW BILL FORD WEIGHING IN ON IT.
THE SYSTEMS ARE FULLY FUNDED
YOU'VE GOT A PLACE AT WORK FOR
YOURSELF THAT WORK FOR ME THAT
WORKING IS BEING REQUESTED A
CALIFORNIA. IS NOT FOR IT I'VE
GOT THE MOST EMPLOYEES IN
SACRAMENTO. GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
STATE CITY AND COUNTY I'VE GOT
THE MOST RETIREES AND SECOND A
COUNTY FOR STATE CITY AND COUNTY
AND IT IS A- IT IS AN ISSUE WITH
IT. WE KEEP SAYING FOSSIL FUELS.
AND IS THIS ONE THING AFTER
ANOTHER. IN THOSE PISTON SYSTEMS
NEED TO BE HOLE. FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK RIGHT NOW
AND RETIREES AND IT'S JUST LIKE
SOME THE THINGS WE DIVESTED
FROM. JUST BECAUSE WE DIVEST
FROM. DOESN'T MEAN THE REST THE
WORLD DIVEST FROM IT AND THE
FOLKS FROM CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS. REALLY GAVE A GREAT
EXAMPLE IN THAT HEARING LAST
WEEK THAT WAS MY COLLEAGUES TO
THE BEEN THERE. TO HEAR THAT IT
IT'S A BIG ISSUE SOMETHING WE
DEALT WITH. ON A REGULAR BASIS
SO. I HEAR YOU WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH
YOU I AGREE WITH YOU. IT'S HOW
WE GO ABOUT IT HOW WE GET THERE.
SO THAT'S BELIEF I DO AGREE WITH
YOU. IT'S HOW WE GET THERE
THAT'S BEEN THE DEVIL IN THE
DETAILS TO GET THERE. BECAUSE IT
IS NOT RIGHT BUT LIKE I SAID.
CALIFORNIA MUST BE OUT FRONT.
AND SOMETIMES ARE OUT FRONT TO
THE DISMAY OF THEIR OWN
CITIZENS. THAT'S WHAT THE COST.
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA SO HIGH.
BY LINE IS MORRIS TO LIVE. THE
GAS IN OUR CARS TO HAVE OUR
UTILITIES IN FOR CELTIC COOK NOW
DOWNTOWN IS FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
THAT IS INSANE. SO THAT IS A LIE
I GUESS I RESPECT MY COLLEAGUE
AND- HE DID SOME VERY VERY GOOD
POINT I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
THINK THEY'RE VERY TIMELY. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER MISTER
NAZARIAN. WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE- ROOM IS THERE ANY-
ANYONE IN HERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN
. SCENE NINE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINES EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. WITH PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN LET'S BEGIN. THANK
YOU FEE LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME AND HAVE
NOT ALREADY DONE SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN Q. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
OUR FIRST LINE IN QUEUES WHICH
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- YES. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
THERE'S ONE LOMBARD. AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MULTIPLE LOCAL
AND STATEWIDE BLACK BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS. WE SENT A LETTER
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE REGARDING
THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTION AGENCY. AS STATED IN
THE LETTER WE SUPPORT APPROVAL
OF THE CPPA BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY WENTY THREE TO ALLOW
THE AGENCY TO START UP. AND
FULFILL THE- IMMEDIATE STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES WE ALSO URGE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO APPROVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO EXPAND
THE AGENCY'S STATUTORY DEADLINE
TO ADOPT PRIVACY REGULATIONS
FROM JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND TO EXPAND PUTTING
ESTONIA ENFORCEMENT DATE FROM
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TO JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. THIS WILL ALLOW THE AGENCY
TO MEET THE STATUTORY MANDATORY-
MANDATE AND MAINTAINED THE
BULL'S OF PROP TWENTY FOUR. THE
AGENCY HAS EXPRESSED CONCERNS
THE LOADING TO LEGISLATIVE HELP
HAVING KNOWLEDGE THEY WILL NOT
MEET THE DELUXE THAT JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE BASED
ON PREVIOUS AGENCY COMMENTS.
SMALL DIVERSE BUSINESSES MAY
FACE IRREPARABLE HARM IF THE
AGENCY IS NOT ABLE TO DEVELOP
REASONABLE AND PRACTICAL PRIVACY
REGULATIONS. AT THE TIME LOCAL
FOR THE STATUTORY DEADLINE OF
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
AGENCY HAS NOT CONDUCTED PRE
RULEMAKING HEARING OUTREACH TO
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. FOLLOWING
STANDARDIZED REGULATORY IMPACT
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE PRIVACY
REGULATION ON SMALL DIVERSE
BUSINESSES THANK AND I DON'T
THINK AMENITIES WRAP UP YOUR
COMMENT. I GET THAT YOU WOULD
APPROVE SOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SO THAT THE TIME FRAME
CAN BE EXTENDED OUT TO JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. CONNECT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIEL MORRIS
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE PAM FIRM BASED OUT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT THE
NATIONAL REACH WHERE BLACK
FEMALE OWNED FIRM WHO PROVIDES
VIRTUAL ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
TO INCREASE OUR CLIENTS BOTTOM
LINE. WITH IT BEING OVER TWO
YEARS NOW SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN IT CONTINUES TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON SMALL BLACK
OWNED BUSINESSES LIKE MINE. ONE
MAJOR FACTOR CONTINUES TO STICK
OUT OF THE PRIMARY REASON I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO KEEP
SERVING MY CLIENTS MY BUSINESS
IS ONLINE PRESENCE. I PERSONALLY
WATCH BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
STATE FORCED TO CLOSE THEIR
DOORS INCLUDING FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS OF MINE WE HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO CONTINUE OFFERING
SERVICES ONLINE. HOWEVER IF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY PUSHES THEIR MAJOR
PRIVACY REGULATIONS WITHOUT
COMPLETE INPUT FROM THE VAST
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WE COULD FACE ANOTHER
DEVASTATING BLOW TO THE WAY WE
DO BUSINESS. WITH THE PPA IS
CURRENT TIMELINE TO COMPLETE THE
ROLE MAKING BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TALE IF YOU HATE THE TO
CREATE SUCH IMPORTANT
REGULATION. OTHER SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE CPPA IS THE
REGULATORY DEADLINE ENFORCEMENT
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA TO
STRENGTHEN CONSUMER PRIVACY WITH
THE IMPACT. ON BUSINESSES IN
MIND THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT
WILL COME FROM LINE SEVENTY NINE
. SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS MAUREEN
MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
REPORTS ON COMMENTING ON THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY I'D LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE REQUEST TO EXTEND THE
AGENCY'S STATUTORY DEADLINE TO
ADOPT PRIVACY REGULATIONS- TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT WOULD
INAPPROPRIATELY DENY CONSUMERS
KEEP PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. TO
WHICH THEY'RE ENTITLED FOR
EXAMPLE PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR
TO CARRY EXPENSE CONSUMERS-
PRODUCTIONS ARE NOT DEPENDENT ON
RULE MAKING TO GO INTO A FACT
FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE DATA
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS TO ALL THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION COVERED BY
THE MEASURE CLARIFIES THE
BUSINESSES MUST ALLOW CONSUMERS
TO OPT OUT OF THE SHARING OF
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION. AND
IT COVERS INFORMATION THE
COMMUTES TO ACCESS ONLINE
ACCOUNT- BY THE PRO RATED ACTION
IN THE EVENT OF A NEGLIGENT DATA
BREACH CONSUMER SHOULD BE FORCED
TO GIVE UP AS PROTECTIONS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE AGENCY WOULD NEED
MORE TIME TO COMPLETE WILL
MAKING PROCESS MOTHER ANY
PLAYING OF COURSE IT WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT
BECAUSE COMPANIES PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR DOUBLE THE
THRESHOLD. FOR THE PRIVACYLOS
ANGELES ALL BUSINESSES ARE
EXEMPTED FROM MEASURE
ENFORCEMENT DELAY WOULD FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE IMBALANCE BETWEEN
THE BIGGEST. AND SMALLEST
BUSINESSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MANAGER AT THIS TIME THEY'RE
KNOWN FOR THEIR MINDS AND Q.
THANK YOU MR PRATER- THAT GIVEN
SAID THIS A BUDGET SUB FOR
HEARING IS NOW CONCLUDED. GEN.